[Music]
did you hear that
what's going on that's a good question
[Music]
this got to be an explanation you know
we ought to do yes sir
we wanted to make history so maybe this
is your chance
[Music]
there are things that you can feel and
not describe
[Music]
for the course of a long man's life he
comes to understand why
he was chosen
[Music]
where are you taking me to the world
all right fellas i'll go in three two
one
[Music]
oh my god it's so great it is gorgeous
up there
oh no it's a song it's in the beach boys
song
wouldn't it be nice
[Music]
you're the girl with the deaf family are
you sick
[Music]
here they come you're in for me
i feel the same way when she sleeps she
turns into a wolf
[Music]
i'm begging you to come back to me the
world deserves to see these
i do believe you have just had a
breakthrough we fight for freedom
only we can shorten the darkness
hey it's a story
we've been working really well together
this is unbelievable
so what do you do i teach fifth grade
shut up i love you
i think we've all had enough of this a
moose boosh time to move on to the main
course
[Music]
you